i know you talked about mitch keller in
our open obviously we know the mo it's
it's it's get ahead it's put guys away
when when you should and when you need
to and he's been doing that the last
several times out so you know he i know
he wants to finish on a good note so
hopefully that same recipe for success
that he's drawn up these last couple
times out that he continues to do it
tonight
and this time oh a diving stop by tucker
from the seat of his pants moran gets
back up and takes the throw how about
that play i mean he basically caught
that ball at a straight up first base
position in the outfield i mean that's
incredible look how close that is to the
first base bag and moran gets back up
and takes the throw
great play by cole tucker
shortstop
newman
onto first so a couple of fine defensive
plays behind
keller puts up the zero alec mills goes
to work sinker four-seam change slider
curveball is the repertoire a good
disbursement of all of those pitches
and that should be ooh safe infield hit
but it should be and it is
continent did all he could he went a
long way to get this ball kevin newman
runs more than well enough to beat that
ball out now brian reynolds
but this is toward the right center
field gap and this is going to get down
cut off by
the right fielder martini and into
second with a hustling double goes brian
reynolds second and third
for colin moran
and that's crack to center field deep
back ortega track
gone clearing the deck with a cannonball
don't you know it's colin moran all the
way to county cork
don't you know
it's three nothing buckos
and a strikeout for mills and that ends
the inning but moran with the big blast
this three-run homer gives the pirates
the lead and three-nothing boston
romaine stands in
that's drilled out to left field that's
a base hit austin roma
and here comes rafael ortega
and that one ripped out towards right
center field romine racing for third
ortega the second throw too late it's a
and
double
cubs are in business two in scoring
position it's second and third
and only one out frank schwendell the
batter cubs trail three nothing
the other way that's a base hit into
right field
romine in to score the hold ortega throw
comes in from gamel
rbi single from frank to tank and the
cubs on the board 3-1 with one out
3-2
and half will take his walk
so they're loaded up comes down a couple
and it's matt duffy
live drive base hit right field ortega
in to score
and they'll hold up schwendell 3-2 now
[Applause]
line drive base hit right field and to
score schwindel to hold half an rbi
single and we're starting over it's 3-3
david bodie now
right to the shortstop and david bode
how frustrated is he right now it's into
another double play
gamell swings and misses at a strike at
a change up for strike three
beautiful pitch by alec mills
good job there back-to-back strikeouts
i know that i mentioned the last four
starts but i i still feel like he's
shown enough as a starter to be capable
we've seen him do this
swaying in a miss and
mills looks sharp strikes out the side
gets them all swimming as ortega draws a
walk and it'll bring up the tank frank
schwendel ashwindell waits for the 2-2
ground ball up the middle and through
for a base hit
a second hit of the game for schwendel
ortega advances to third and the cubs in
business here in the top half of the
fifth inning men at the corners and no
one out ian happ will step into the box
base hit right field half with the knock
in the score
is raphael ortega schwendell to 30 and
hat has given the cubs the lead and matt
duffy rbi knock his last time
that's drilled to center field going
back reynolds back some more and it hits
the base of the wall
into scorish windell half will stop at
third matt duffy an rbi single it's 5-3
there's martini against the lefty
anthony bondis
in the air left field alford right there
makes the catch tagging from third his
hat throw is cut off and it's a
sacrifice fly by nick martini what a
nightmare he's had
rolled on the right side tucker
and that'll do it cubs take the lead
with a three spot in the fifth the
pirates trailing six to three it'll be
brian reynolds colin moran and jacob
stallings against alec mills
and reynolds is three for three he's not
done yet not going to concede anything
colin moran has homered and walked
and the red beard takes another walk
well now mills very quickly has brought
the tying run to the plate and nobody
out
and a base hit to left for stallings
reynolds will be held and they are
loaded gamble over two
three and one
and into center field
that will score a run sacrifice fly nice
job by ortega to keep runner at second
so gamma gets the sacrifice fly and it's
6-4
here's holy park who has lined out and
struck out
toward right center field how about hoy
park oh he splits the gap and that
scores moran
stallings will score into third with a
trip
trip
game tying triple
hoy park
and now it's trevor mcgill
face the pinch hitter michael chavis
and to right field for michael chavis to
give the pirates the lead
we're talking to neil walker about the
difficulty of pinch hitting how about a
guy
just activated today off the injured
list
and facing a hard-throwing right-hander
and michael chavis whacks it into right
and the pirates take a 7-6 lead
and it brings up brian reynolds what's
next for b-ray
it's this hard towards center field
sending ortega back and he's there oh no
he can't hold on
this will be an interesting ruling from
the official score that's a tough play
yeah but he had it in his glove uh e8
scoring yeah i mean it's in the glove
there's colin moran
ground ball base hitting the right here
comes reynolds and the pirates take an
8-6 lead colin moran on base for a
fourth straight time and he has four
ribbies
wilson contreras is gonna hit for david
the payoff
and stratton will get saved number seven
raise the jolly roger
great start to the final home stand of
the year